hello and welcome to the shaky sign show
in this video we'll look at annum on the
what the why and the when with aging and
happy new year I now have a new logo and
a new microphone that I'm testing which
I don't think is any better but we'll
just go with it and so the idea for this
video pretty much came from last week's
video when I discussed David's and
Claire's recent book life span which you
should check out as well and so this
video is going to look at animate AUSA
is I'm really going to the science
behind it and this is mainly why I made
the video it's why are people taking it
and what is the link between nmn and
aging I thought was interesting from his
books I got a little bit further with
that and also when should you start
taking it if you should start taking it
these all kinds of the questions that
I'm going to discuss in this video but
firstly what actually is an ax men what
my name is mo no you must know it's not
that any men this is why I'm a scientist
not a rapper so element actually stands
for nicotinamide mononucleotide and it
is a precursor for nad so na d stands
for nicotinamide adenine dinucleotide
and it's a really important cofactor in
biological systems in fact you could
argue that nad is the most important
molecule in the body maybe with the
exception of ATP but without either of
them you're dead and around 30 seconds
that's what Davidson classes and she's
right in order to understand why people
would take any men you have to
understand why we need nad and so as I
said without explaining nad is a key
factor and say cofactors are required
for enzymes activity and enzymes are
proteins that catalyze by chemical
reactions within cells and nad it's one
of the most abundant molecules within
the human body and it's required to
around 500 different enzymatic reactions
and apparently the average person has
around three grams of nad within
themselves and say nad has two main
functions the first one is as a redox
coenzyme so this is where acts as a key
factor with the metabolic enzymes
and secondly as a substrate for nad
dependent enzymes so I should really be
saying nad plus because it is the
oxidized form that is used in these
different cases and so nad plus is
essential for certain activation and say
certains are these nad consuming enzymes
I just mentioned and energy is also
essential for metabolism as I said and
that's including the metabolism of fatty
acids and glucose and associated with
that it's the generation of ATP which is
like the cell's energy source and then
lastly well there's many things that are
central for but it's also essential for
activating DNA repair enzymes and again
there's a family of these enzymes that
are NAD+ consuming enzymes so we can see
that nad plus is important but what is
the driving factor behind the the use of
supplementation initially we already
have energy plus in our bodies
why take more well as I've written out
energy plus levels decline as we age
when we have more DNA damage and during
alcohol metabolism
however energy plus levels can be
restored during energy deficiency so
that includes fasting calorie
restriction and through exercise but an
alternative potentially more efficient
and more effective way of restoring nad
Plus levels is to supplement with and a
men so important point here as far as
I'm aware there is no definitive proof
that taking any men would have a
beneficial effects on humans however
there's lots of evidence from studies in
yeast worms and mice where animun has
actually increased the NAD+ levels and
this protected against a variety of age
associated declines within them such as
the kinds of mitochondrial dysfunction
declines in physical performance muscle
regeneration arterial dysfunction and
also prevented from the clients in
fission and in insulin resistance so
like have you diabetes in addition you
can see metabolic and neuro protective
benefits but why and how so to
understand this a bit more we need to go
into the
raishin and use of NAD+ so as I already
mentioned nmn is a precursor for nad
plus and another molecule called Anna or
nicotinamide web aside to be more
precise can also be converted to Elliman
and MN cannot be converted back to Anna
and so what I've written out in black
here are just a different enzyme and say
you've got C D 73 and RK and I meant 80
don't worry about what they stand for
this is way more information than I was
meant to be giving you for my queen says
is that there are these precursors that
generates NAD+ and you also may have had
about element forces and R which is
better and I might do a subsequent video
and look into more detail between the T
because it is interesting I see what
could potentially be more effective but
as you can see the metabolism of MIT
it's actually quite complicated and to
be honest we don't fully understand that
either at the moment there are different
pathways that are being discovered still
today so yeah we don't have a full
picture of the metabolism yet but you
have roots of generating NAD+ from n MN
but also they Navy from precursor such
as tryptophan and another molecule you
might have heard about is an a.m. which
is nicotinamide and say n a.m. is
generated as a product by these NAD+
consuming enzymes so this includes
statins cd38 and pop one so I'm pretty
sure I probably confuse you by this
point so I'm going to simplify it a bit
further and just focus on the generation
of n a.m. from the use of sirtuin
activity because that is the most
interesting in terms of understanding
the link between
NAD+ and aging so now you might be
wondering well what's a sirtuins or
settlements i don't know how you
pronounce it that I gave statins
apologies so certains are a family which
is nice and they are a family of NAD+
dependent the ass laces and I'll show
you what that means in a second and in
humans we have seven seconds so that's
one to start seven and they have a
variety of different rating targets and
functions
one study I mean statins really deserve
a failure of their own but one study has
shown in yeast that when they added a
copy of the gene 30 there was a 30%
extension in lifespan so you don't
really need to know what acyl groups are
but a type of acyl groups known as
acetal can be attached to proteins and
what's earth Wednesday when bound by
energy plus is they remove this as
photography from the protein and so
proteins can do different things with
them without acetal groups and see the
process of the removal of a cell from
certain proteins that are activated by
side winds enables its prey teams to go
on and activate stress resistance
responses within the cell that is
thought to be the help and lifespan
beneficial response so during this
reaction
NAD+ is used up and the products that
form one is an ADP ribose derivative
that you don't need to worry about in
this case what is I'm not going to talk
about it and and you also get n a.m.
which is just nicotinamide and we've
already looked at how n am can be
compared about an Amman and then back to
NAD+ but the point is for statins to
continue their activity they need NAD+
they can't work with any M or n MN so
the idea behind supplementation is that
she counteracts the loss of energy plus
you can increase the levels of n MN and
therefore you in theory should generate
more nad plus so for further reading and
from listening to many David Sinclair
interviews there are some arguments that
you must take n MN with another compound
known as miss Farrell so the reasoning
behind this is that the two of them
together can have an enhanced effects so
this is because
resveratrol target sirtuins and
increases their activity whereas n MN
increases the levels of led which is
kind of like the source where insert
ones have that and somatic activity so
resveratrol could be seen as the driver
and MN as the source but this is merely
me just speculating as to what might be
the reason there is no definitive
evidence out there that does prove this
to be the case at least that I'm aware
of
so another question while
asking is why do energy plus levels
declined during aging in the first place
so there is likely a variety of reasons
for Hawaii
NAD+ level decline but one recent bit of
evidence shows that the activity of cd38
increases during aging in which case I
might explain the increased usage of
NAD+ so you hopefully now have a good
understanding about why there's these
discussions about I know men are
supplements but the last question I'll
address is well when should we take in
our men and so that refers to beef when
during your lifespan you should start
taking it but also when during the day
so I'm going to tell you now before I
forget we don't know the answer to
either these questions right now but
what I will do is tell you what we do
know or try to understand at the moment
and also give some my own hypothetical
ideas
so one thing we do know is that levels
of NAD+ change throughout the day so for
example we know that levels increase
after you exercise and decrease when
you've just eaten so when should an ax
men be taken well honestly I don't know
and it's going to vary depending on the
individual because everyone has their
own routines as to when they eat do
whatever and also it would depend on
whether you take the days all at once or
or if the doses bit up throughout the
day but now this is the fun bit I can at
least be hypothetical about what
potentially could be happening so as you
can see I'm drawing out a graph to plot
a potential hypothetical fluctuations of
NAD+ levels throughout the day and what
a question that I would be interesting
to ask is is it best to add any men when
your levels of NAD+ are already high so
maybe at the end of the fast period or
to take any men when your levels of NAD+
already low and they say you can try and
up that you know decrease the depth of
the trough and increase or you could
increase the crust I don't if I made any
sense but you know use that's the
question so it reminds me of that cleats
that those are things that we know and
those are things that we know that we
don't know such as there
and those are things that we don't know
that we don't know I'm already confused
basically this is a lot we date thank
you and just add to the complexity we
also know that NAD+ is important for
driving the circadian rhythm so the
circadian rhythm is the rhythm that goes
on them ourselves that's around 24 hours
and that regulates rhythms in behavior
physiology metabolism and selectivity
and I have an entire video on that that
I'll link but you should check out but
we also know that as I said NAD+ drives
Acadian rhythm and yes as kraits is
actually comes from Davidson cloud so
it's interesting that led Plus isn't
being driven by the clock it is the
clock is driven by MIT Plus but it's
very complicated and um I haven't fully
understood it myself yet why don't they
anyone fully understand it yet but I
might make a video on it why probably
we'll all right so the second aspect of
when is output age within your life
should you start taking and a man if you
should start taking in a man remember
that there is no definitive proof that
it's effective yet it's all safe in
humans so again you know we just don't
know if the answer to this question and
see anything we can kind of base the on
at the moment it studies opens on a mice
and say um it comes down to when does
aging really begin and so I have a video
on home automation which you should
check out and we know that well there
seems to be evidence now at least that's
David suppliers mentioned that we are
aging constantly even before were born
and so basically the what we've got from
that is that well the earlier the better
but after development because I mean
there's just hasn't been enough studies
to really know the role of NAD+ during
development and how that differs between
its role during adulthood so what David
Sinclair had said in there a recent
interview is that around twenty four
twenty five years old might be good oh
well we don't never say but might be the
right hand start anyway as I said I'm
healthy how safe is it
is the biggest question right now you
know if you start taking at a younger
age I is there gonna be some consequence
increased cancer risk we didn't
astronaut moment and the thing is we
still need to have Studies on an amend
to show you that it's taken in humans so
they focus the plan I'll talk a bit more
about the safety sides in my next video
and also maybe at some point I try and
compare any men and and are as I already
said earlier but hopefully this video
has been a good introduction to the bots
why and when with nmn in aging so as
always thanks for listening